Якщо вже воювати, то воювати в боєздатному підрозділі,
в підготовленому війську.
Наша задача - проштурмувати, тобто забрати ці окопи
у ворога, зайняти їх.
Тебе везуть, ти сидиш, і все. Ти нічого не можеш зробити.
Це дуже страшно!
Вже навіть бійці США визнають те, що вони вчаться в нас.
Тобто не ми в них.
Ти там знаходишся, ти твориш історію, і ти в якійсь мірі,
записуєш себе в історію. Ну, а після штурму, коли ти повертаєшся,
перше, що ти думаєш, що ти живий.
Клас! Все, живий, слава Богу!
Якщо вже воювати, то воювати в боєздатному підрозділі,
в підготовленому війську. Тобто чим ми відрізняємося -
це високим рівнем підготовки. І навіть багато військових визнають,
що 3-тя штурмова набула статусу елітної бригади.
І хотілось воювати з найкращими пліч-о-пліч.
Розумів, що в таких більш активних, контактних підрозділах
медиків не вистачає.
Я цілий час з групою. Але оскільки я медик, я трошки позаду від групи,
від основної, від ударної, скажімо так.
Але так, я разом з ними постійно. І в разі необхідності
я можу займати абсолютно будь-яку позицію.
Раніше мій рюкзак був менший, тому що була така мобільна робота
і був постійно медевак поруч. Тобто я працював і як на виході,
так і на медеваку, і я знав, що медевак - це машина медична -
вона десь неподалік. А в цій машині відповідно все,
що треба для допомоги є. Тому це був невеличкий рюкзачок,
щоб, скажімо так, на коліні швиденько підлатати.
Зараз доводиться із собою навіть інфузії носити.
Інфузії, тобто розчини для капання бійців.
Тому що інколи евакуація - досить складний процес.
Не завжди може транспорт заїхати і забрати важкопоранених.
Ми можемо сидіти в окопах, але це короткий проміжок часу,
тому що ми штурмовий підрозділ.
Наша задача - проштурмувати, тобто забрати ці окопи у ворога, зайняти їх.
І потім там ми закріплюємось.
У межах нашої бригади є артилерія і аеророзвідка,
і різні типи озброєння, які дуже часто прикривають нас.
Аеророзвідка нам допомагає дізнатися,
що перед нами навіть, коли ми штурмуємо.
Ми знаходимося на полі бою і ми, здавалося, бачимо все.
Але коли над нами висить наш дрон, він бачить вперед на 100-200 метрів
і він може нас попереджати, чи підтягуються якісь резерви,
що там відбувається, чи вони навпаки відступають.
Перший штурм - це невідомість. Ти йдеш в якусь невідомість.
Так, тренування були до цього, хлопці досвідчені
діляться досвідом, розказують, що і як відбувається.
Ти дивишся відео зі штурмів, як це відбувається.
Плюс самопідготовка - література і все тому подібне.
Але все одно, ти їдеш, ти цього раніше не пробував,
ти цього раніше не робив - це невідомість.
Плюс нас якраз у мій перший штурм дуже прекрасно зустрічали
мінометним вогнем протягом 14 годин.
Було страшно, десь весело, десь не дуже…
Ну, але перший штурм пройшов, ти зрозумів в принципі,
що можна жити. Можна жити, можна працювати.
А далі вже по накатаній.
Ми вчимось абсолютно всьому. Абсолютно всьому і постійно.
Тобто якщо ми не воюємо, якщо у нас відпочинок якийсь,
у нас постійно йдуть тренування. Ці тренування направлені
як на фізичні можливості, тобто це фізпідготовка,
це і полігони, тактика, тактична медицина, топографія,
радіозв'язок, тобто абсолютно все. Тренуємо абсолютно все.
І це цікавіше. Ти знаєш, на що ти можеш розраховувати
під час екстрених ситуацій, на що ти можеш розраховувати
в плані реакції своєї.
Тому що у нас тренування максимально наближені
до бойових дій. Ти вже просто коли знаходишся на полі бою,
твої інстинкти падають до рівня твоїх знань.
Ти просто робиш все на автоматі.
У мене страх, як, мабуть, у більшості моїх побратимів, піхотинців,
це страх під час заходу на позицію.
Тобто коли ти ще їдеш в транспорті, і ця невідомість,
коли ти не бачиш, що навколо відбувається,
і коли від тебе нічого не залежить.
Тобто тебе везуть, ти сидиш, і все. Ти нічого не можеш зробити.
Це дуже страшно!
А коли вже ти приїхав, коли ти вивантажуєшся з транспорту
і коли перед тобою посадка, ти вже знаєш, що тобі треба робити.
І тут вже майже все залежить від того, наскільки ти натренований.
Тобто так, є фактор, який називається везіння.
Але знову ж таки, цей фактор можна зменшити,
якщо ти правильно дієш під час штурму.
Ми відрізняємося від більшості військовослужбовців,
тому що у нас майже все, що можна обвісити бронею, ми обвішуємо.
Броня - починаючи від шиї, закінчуючи ногами.
Тобто це манжети, наплічники, напашники, броня на поперек.
Коли ми заходимо, противник завжди знає, що ми заходимо.
Він ніколи не шкодує на нас БК.
Тобто це постійно мінометний чи артобстріл, обстріл з АГС-ів
і в досить великій кількості.
Тому, можливо, ми не хотіли б стільки броні,
але ми просто вимушені носити, тому що осколки
постійно літають десь біля нас.
Загалом повністю вся екіпіровка, плюс додатковий БК
і, в залежності від спеціалізації, хто гранатометник, хто медик,
хто кулеметник, вся екіпіровка може вважити до 50 кілограмів.
Інколи це можуть бути марші по 5-8 кілометрів.
І це добре, якщо це марші по прямій дорозі!
А якщо це по розбитій посадці, то просто не витримають
деякі хлопці, які недостатньо треновані.
Про стандарти НАТО тут, мабуть, вже можна сказати,
і це вже не мої здогадки, а побратими спілкуються
з бійцями НАТО, конкретно з морпіхами, з американцями,
і вже навіть бійці США визнають те, що вони вчаться в нас.
Ми використовуємо як НАТОвські підходи до війни,
так і з радянської школи теж можна взяти якісь окремі уроки,
і на власному досвіді якісь стратегії, тактики вироблені.
Тому це все змішується, міксується, плюс досвід наших командирів.
Як відомо, майже всі наші командири, це вихідці з "Азова",
завдяки їм і живе ідейність "Азова",
вони підтримують наші бойові навички.
Я брав участь у штурмах під Андріївкою.
Підходи до Андріївки, Андріївку.
Бої були важкі. Там було дуже важко, дуже велика концентрація ворога
була, але ворог виявився не такий мотивований,
не такий підготований, як ми.
Це для цивільних відповідь. 72-а мотобригада їхня,
"Шторм-Z", їхній підрозділ тюремників,
яких набрали просто як "м'ясо".
Були ще якісь підрозділи десантних військ, наскільки я знаю.
Один раз навіть, під час мого виходу, навіть "Ахмат Сила" приїхала.
Правда, ненадовго…
Росіяни добре копають, для оборони їхні окопи, їхні бліндажі
дуже прекрасно підходять. Ховатись у них можна,
перечікувати обстріли в них можна.
Ну так, щоб жити... Мабуть, ні.
Тому що це проміжкові точки і проміжкові позиції.
Під час штурмів це не якась там лінія оборони.
Коли йде активний штурм, викопуються позиції нашвидкуруч,
просто щоб було де пересидіти.
Коли ти звикаєш, умовно кажучи, до посадки і до того,
що відбувається в посадці, і коли ти повертаєшся в цивільне життя
- є певний ступор, є певна дезорієнтація.
Відчувається різниця в цінностях, мабуть, так можна це назвати.
Я б не сказав, що це гнів. Це якесь відчуття певної несправедливості
- так воно є. Війна йде. Але ж це не означає, що людям
треба закритись в підвалі і чекати.
Люди мають право на відпочинок, на ще щось…
Просто це особисте відчуття несправедливості.
А так - злості, негативу якогось абсолютно немає.
Наш підрозділ - підрозділ націоналістів.
Ми вмотивовані, мабуть, ну не знаю, більше, чи не більше за всіх,
але ми вмотивовані і штурм, скажімо так,
це для нас якогось роду визнання.
Тобто ти там знаходишся, ти твориш історію, і ти в якійсь мірі,
записуєш себе в історію. Ну, а після штурму, коли ти повертаєшся,
перше, що ти думаєш, що ти живий. Клас! Все, живий, слава Богу!